في مدينة أوتريخت ، خارج
أمستردام مباشرةً ، تلعب رئيسة بلدية أمستردام ، شارون ديكسما ،
دورها في المعركة ضد تغير
المناخ ، ويقوم الكثير من الناس هنا حسب بعض
التقديرات ، باستخدام أكثر من 90 في المائة من
السكان هنا للدراجات
للتنقل ، المدينة هي موطن
لأكبر مرآب للدراجات.  في العالم في
شوارعنا ، السيارات ضيوف
وأعتقد أن المشاة
والأشخاص الذين يسافرون على الدراجات هم الذين
يسيطرون على الطريق في الواقع ، لا
يتعلق الأمر فقط بتبني خيارات النقل الأخضر
من مبنى مجتمع الغابات العمودي
إلى الألواح الشمسية في معظم
تم التعرف على أسطح المدينة في أوتريخت
كنموذج للاستدامة
، وأعتقد أن المدينة المستدامة تحتاج إلى
نهج شامل لذلك لا
تعمل فقط على التنقل المستدام ولكنك
تحتاج أيضًا إلى تحقيق انتقال الطاقة حقًا
لذلك نحاول
إخراج المنازل من الغاز  ومن أجل استخدام
الطاقة الشمسية أو طاقة الرياح ، فإن
الالتزام بتغير المناخ
مستمر منذ سنوات في عام 2016 ، وقعت
على اتفاقية مناخ باريس  اتفقت نيابة عن
الاتحاد الأوروبي وتخطط هذا العام
لعرض مدينتها كمثال
على الاستدامة للمناطق الحضرية الأخرى
في cop 27 الذي سيعقد في
منتجع الشاطئ المصري في شارما الشيخ
، أنا عمدة ونعتقد أن
يجب سماع صوت المدن في الكأس
لأن المدن هي الأماكن التي
يحدث فيها التلوث ولكننا أيضًا
جزء من حل المشكلات
وفقًا لمدن الأمم المتحدة في جميع أنحاء
العالم مسؤولة عن ما يقرب من 75 في المائة من
انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون و  مع توقع أن يعيش أكثر من 65 في
المائة من سكان العالم
في المناطق الحضرية بحلول عام 2050 ، يحتل موضوع
المدن المستدامة مكانة عالية على
جدول أعمال المؤتمر في مصر
، كما ذكرت المناقشة أن المدن
والنقل المستدام والحلول
ستركز على كيف يمكننا أن نتحمل.
جانب تنفيذ قصص النجاح
والمدن مثل أوتريخت ورئيس
البلدية يمهدان الطريق لمستقبل أكثر نظافة
CNN
[موسيقى]